you
[Music]
my journey to this conference started
one year and one day ago as with many of
you it started with a tweet from Hadley
Wickham how much more could you want
than this our studio is hiring a
director of Education please apply if
you love stats in education well now at
this time I was teaching big data for a
consulting company that had been
acquired by a very large technology
company and and I was putting on about a
hundred thousand air miles per year at
that level you get to know the TSA folks
on a first-name basis hey Tom how's the
wife and kids and it seemed like staying
around home might be a little bit more
fun so I interviewed with basically my
heroes Garret gorilla Minh Minh a
Chechen guy arundel Hadley Wickham
finally it comes to the point where I
interview with tarif who's the president
of our studio and I'm a little nervous
and I get a little bit more nervous when
he tells me you know I'm not sure you're
who we're looking for
I don't think you're gonna work out
because cuz we're thinking a little bit
bigger than you are
we're thinking that we really want to
equip everyone regardless of means to
participate in a global economy that
rewards data literacy whoa so I had to
come think about that and we had coffee
scheduled for the next day and I came in
and I met with him again and I gave him
my best shot
and as a result I am now the director of
education at our studio and the shot I
gave him was this this is what's called
a bee hag a big hairy audacious goal
comes from an old book called a built to
last and my bee hag was really simple
our co-education mission is going to be
to train the
next million our users now this sounds
sort of preposterous when you first
think about it but frankly it's smaller
than the population of San Jose not so
bad and it is a little larger than the
number of people who own Klingon
dictionaries by the way there are
300,000 people that own Klingon
dictionaries this particular one says I
must attend our studio conf so it's easy
to make a big big hairy audacious goal
but how do you execute on it right so
I'm a member of AAA know I'm not an
alcoholic I'm actually a analysts
Anonymous I was an industry analyst for
15 years and when you ask an analyst you
know tell me how are you gonna do
something they start asking questions
back and my questions were well who
learns are and why do they learn are and
how do they learn are and what keeps
them from learning are well again
analysts are trained to do this I said
well the clear way we answer these
questions is we do a survey and and I
brought this up to Hadley as a proposal
for doing this talk and Hadley comes
back and serves at G using data to make
decisions
hmm I think I've heard of that somewhere
before so so on December 6th I put out
this tweet of my own which is do you
wonder how and why people learn our and
if you've learned or are planning to
learn our fill out our five-minute
survey now thanks to Laura ASEAN who's
in Argentina we also got a
spanish-language translation of the
entire survey this went up a few days
later and as a result we actually
gathered data so today I'm here to
announce the our Studios learning our
survey is now published it was filled in
between December sixth and December 31st
the respondents were solicited from
community our studio comm Twitter
followers of our studio employees and
colleagues and reddit.com data science
what he is really terrific is we
received 3,300 respond
I would have been happy with about a
thousand but 3300 about 10% are
spanish-speaking and all of this data is
now at this repo every single bit of
data we collected and all the plots I'm
about to show you are available for you
to peruse and the code necessary to
analyze it it's about two thousand lines
of our markdown now here's what we have
to do the warning messages first warning
significant sampling bias may be present
these results are not necessarily
representative of the general our
population this is in fact 3,300 of our
Studios closest friends the other thing
is there's a lot of open text in this
survey and that means if you're in K
through 12 and you want to teach your
kids data science using this survey you
should know that this is restricted data
under 17 requires accompanying parent or
guardian so just be very very aware of
that
now we're gonna blast through the data
there's no way I can do in 20 minutes
any real honor to this data but let me
just give you the highlights who learns
are well here's a choropleth of the
respondents to our survey we got
respondents responses from 110 different
countries these are their top ten again
thanks to Laura we have Argentina as
number three she tweeted through our
ladies their most respondents considered
themselves to be intermediate users
they're not experts they're not
beginners and three percent say none and
those are really important people
because those are the people were trying
to reach males made up about seventy
five percent of respondents I had
thought we were doing better on
diversity than we are
this is some area we have some work to
do the mean age was 35 although there's
clearly a long tail you can see where I
am I'm kind of over towards the
right-hand side there and respondents
started learning are at a mean age of 30
so basically most people in our survey
had an average
a level of experience with our I'm about
five years although clearly this big
tails on both ends our community mostly
has advanced degrees Masters is number
one doctorate number two bachelor number
three so these are pretty educated
people and almost half of them work in
research or education so so a very
educated group but also working in the
research or education community
technologies number three and health and
medicines number four so that's who
answered our survey let's go on - why do
they learn our well okay this is where
we start getting into data that that's
gonna make you go
most of them learn it to do this skill
analysis okay but what's interesting is
about one in six did this because
they're personally interested interested
they're interested in learning stats so
that's kind of cool and about 13% said
they're they think it'll open new career
opportunities so that's really neat so
we have so okay what tools do you use
with our and here we get we get some or
what applications you use I'm sorry
and here statistical analysis number one
again visualization number two and in
fact there's some detail here that's
interesting in the english-language
version visualization visualizations
number one spanish-language statistics
is number one so a little bit of
difference between the two populations
so how do they learn are this is
education so we want to know how they're
learning and and respondents mostly
learn are on their own to me this is
obvious but at the same time I think one
of the biggest takeaways from this
survey people are learning are on their
own it's a problem actually and as we'll
see
I had thought online courses would be
higher but it's not people are using
books and online materials Stack
Overflow
you can actually learn are from Stack
Overflow
we don't recommend it if you heard VNA's
talked this morning exploration is not
the most efficient way to get there but
but it's certainly one of the ways you
can learn if we think about some of our
own packages like the tidy verse has
that had any effect only 45% learned
using the tidy verse but today do you
use the tidy verse when you use are
today 67% two thirds of people are using
the tidy verse so I think tidy verse has
really moved the needle now one one
question I like to ask this is a very
specific question it's used for
computing something called the Net
Promoter Score people are really excited
about our they love our and as a matter
of fact when we ask this question how
likely are you to recommend our to a
colleague friend or a family member we
get a net promoter score of 71 percent
or at 71 it doesn't have a percentage
and that is actually excellent if it
were four points higher it would be
world class that type of loyalty cannot
be bought it's a fabulous number it's in
the level of a brands like Apple and
Google and things of that sort the tools
that people use the IDE gets love from
our friends no surprise there but look
Microsoft Excel still showing up there
we have to reach Excel users alright the
last bit of data what keeps them from
learning are so we'll start with the are
users themselves what did they find most
difficult and number one is error
messages I don't think that's any
surprise to any of us but let's look at
the non our users so it's a pretty small
sample here so so beware these numbers
are a little squishy but nonetheless
language syntax is number one getting
started is number two so quick recap the
majority of our users are pretty
sophisticated and educated researchers
they learn are by themselves and not
necessarily through formal courses and
one of their biggest challenges for
learners is getting started okay so what
what can we do so here's where I want to
just give you a few activities we're
doing within our studio and within our
education department the first thing we
can do is hire more teachers that can
HR I have the privilege of working with
what I believe are some of the best
teachers in the world for teaching this
you've met most of them at this at this
conference some of them have spoken
either yesterday or today but I wanted
to alert people to the fact that we've
hired a couple more Greg Wilson I'll
talk about him in a moment
Alison Hill is actually here today
handling this session and if you were in
the advanced armed markdown session you
would have seen her teach for the entire
first day of that fabulous people you're
going to see them on the same page as
all the other teachers soon because they
are real stars but we're announcing a
program today called our Studio
certified teachers these are new
programming's new programs beginning
this month it's a two level program with
both instructors and coaches so the idea
is we can certify instructors but we can
also certify other people to certify
instructors this is headed up by Greg
Wilson who is the co-founder of software
carpentry also a former professor at the
University of Toronto this certifies
teaching skills and knowledge of our
studio tools and we think this is going
to be great for driving a whole new
cadre of teachers so that's step one
more teachers but remember most people
are self taught so we need more tools as
well so here's one that most people
should know but they probably don't that
we provide free academic licensing for
all of our our studio professional
software it's free all you have to do is
give us a course syllabus and any
certified academic institution I don't
care with your k12 community college
university doesn't matter you get our
tools for free if you're doing research
rather than teaching you get a 50%
discount we want you to use our
professional tools and all the details
are on a website under the pricing page
so that's tool number one tool number
two is data science in a box this is an
initiative that Minnetonka Arundel's
started based upon our experience
Dook it's an entire introductory
statistics course with all the slides
although exercises all the exams all the
answers
well don't show your students the
answers but but nonetheless it has
everything you need to really teach a
course this is open source go to data
science box org and you can get all the
materials and start teaching with them
that's number two number three is online
books we don't often think about this
many of the people at our studio are
authors and they've negotiated with
their publishers so they can actually
publish their books online for free so
our for data science if you didn't know
this this is available online for free
you can go in and read the latest
version and Vann star is also online
blog down creating websites with our
markdown hands-on program with our I've
thrown it another one geo computation in
our simply because it's a book I've been
learning from lately and it what I love
about it is it targets an audience that
is not a data scientist if somebody
wants to create Maps do geographical
information systems so I love this book
because it's entirely different area of
investigation the next tool I'm going to
talk about is one I'm not going to talk
about you're going to hear from our CTO
cloud from Mel Gregory but it's probably
one of the most important introductions
we've done this is going to allow you to
do anything that we do on the
professional tools in the cloud that's
Mel she's coming up at 2:09 today right
here in this room don't go anywhere
but as part of that we do have primers
these are tutorials for people who want
to learn on their own you can create an
account at our Studio cloud and just go
in and learn our and it's free so this
is another way that we're allowing
people to self teach to really learn how
to use are on their own but there's one
more thing and I just want to leave you
with this one one more piece of data
that I think is really key we've heard
it a little bit in the prior talks here
but I want we have data to support this
so if we ask people what they love most
about using iron we actually asked it in
kind of that way what do we discover
community is number one the community is
really what makes this work now here's
the sad part also in the data fifteen
percent of our users have no one else in
their work group that knows our they're
completely on their own
if we have if we add in one person is
zero or one it's one in four twenty five
percent have no one to work with when
they're doing our and as all of you know
it's one of the exciting things about
using our it's being of those share your
results publish them so I challenge each
of you to go off and teach art to a
colleague this is why I felt pretty good
about my B hag I'm pretty sure we can
teach a million our users each if every
one of you goes off and grabs a
colleague and says let me tell you how
you can do that thing you're doing in
Excel and do it repeatedly and reliably
I say those words specifically remember
back to tarrifs talk yesterday seems
like forever ago doesn't it
but Treves talked when he opened the
conference the printing press was a new
way of communicating with the rest of
the world it was a way to share
knowledge these tools are the tools we
sell our things that allow us to create
our own knowledge we start from data we
create open processes that can be
verified by other people and then we
create provably if not correct at least
close to correct results we are the
people that are creating knowledge and
that's why we believe that by training
the next million our users we can equip
everyone regardless of means to
participate in a global economy that
rewards data literacy and each one of
you is going to be a part of that thank
you very much
okay we have time for a few questions
no questions oh I see a few there's one
in the back over there there's lots of
data to play with I encourage anybody
who's interesting the data to go do that
I mean it right here and my main
question is are you considering a bill
consider public health as research
regarding the the tools that our CEO
provide and my second question is when
you're reaching out for teaching are you
looking for so specific area like Public
Health we little bit stuck with us
because it was kind of funded by the
federal government and people don't have
anything else to use but what is
available to them thank you so so I'm
not sure I heard the first part of the
question very well could you say it
again and that's the most important
question is the you said our CEO is
providing the tool half price I think
for research and free for education web
Public Health fall is research or
whatever you call it to benefit from
those discount what what results have we
seen from this maybe if I could rephrase
the question are you trying to figure
out if public health as a as an area of
study as considered research or teaching
and if you get the 50% off versus the
full free is that okay the the the easy
decisions do you have a syllabus of
teaching for students if you have a
syllabus then you're a teacher if you
don't have a syllabus if you're doing
research
then you're a researcher it's really
that simple
so depending on what country you're
you're working in like they are if
you're sort of in the what do they call
the emerging countries there's a
significant discount for that too sorry
I mean yeah I would encourage you to
reach out if that's what your use cases
what if you knew what Washington say
it's probably not an emerging country
[Laughter]
[Music]